welcome back everyone this is part three
in our series on analysis methods for
NLP we're going to be focused on feature
attribution methods
I should say at the start that to keep
things manageable we're going to mainly
focus on integrated gradients from
cindera Rajan at all 2017. this is a
shining powerful inspiring example of an
attribution method for reasons I will
discuss but it's by no means the only
method in this space for One-Stop
shopping on these methods I recommend
the captain.ai library it will give you
access to lots of gradient based methods
like IG as well as many others including
more traditional methods like feature
ablation and feature permutation
so check out Captain AI in addition if
you would like a deeper dive on the
calculations and examples that I use in
the screencast I recommend the notebook
feature attribution which is part of the
course code Repository
now I love the integrated gradients
paper sundara Rajan at all 2017 because
of its method but also because it offers
a really nice framework for thinking
about attribution in general and they do
that in the form of three axioms I'm
going to talk about two of them and of
the two of the most important one is
sensitivity this is very intuitive
the Axiom of sensitivity for attribution
methods says if two inputs x and x Prime
differ only at Dimension I and lead to
different predictions then the feature
associated with Dimension I has non-zero
attribution
so here's a quick example our model is m
and it takes inputs that are
three-dimensional and for input 1 0 1
this model outputs positive
and for one one one it outputs negative
that's a difference in the predictions
and that means that the feature in
position two here must have non-zero
attribution seems very intuitive because
obviously this feature is important to
the behavior of this model
just quickly I'll mention a second Axiom
implementation invariance if two models
M and M Prime have identical input
output Behavior then the attributions
for M and M Prime are identical that's
very intuitive if the models can't be
distinguished behaviorally then we
should give them identical attributions
we should not be sensitive to kind of
incidental details of how they were
structured or how they were implemented
let's begin with a kind of Baseline
method gradients by inputs this is very
intuitive and makes uh some kind of
sense from the perspective of doing
feature attribution in deep networks
what we're going to do is calculate the
gradients for our model with respect to
the chosen feature that we want to
Target and multiply that value by the
actual value of the feature so gradients
by inputs it's called gradients by
inputs but obviously we could do this
kind of gradient taking with respect to
any neuron in one of these deep learning
models and multiply it by the actual
value of that neuron for some example
and so actually this method generalizes
really nicely to any state in a deep
learning model
it's really straightforward to implement
that I've depicted that on the slide
here the first implementation uses raw
Pi torch and the second one is just a
lightweight wrapper around the captain
implementation of input by gradient
so it shows you how straightforward this
can be
one issue that I want to linger over
here that I find conceptually difficult
is this question of how we should do the
attributions for classifier models we
have a choice we can take attributions
with respect to the predicted labels or
with respect to the actual labels which
are two different dimensions in the
output Vector for these models
now if the model you're studying is very
high performing then the predicted and
actual labels will be almost identical
and this is unlikely to matter but you
might be trying to study a really poor
performing model to try to understand
where its deficiencies lie and that's
precisely the case where these two will
come apart as an illustration on this
slide here I've defined a simple make
classification synthetic problem using
scikit-learn it has four features and
then I set up a shallow neural
classifier and I deliberately under
trained it it has just one training
iteration
this is a very bad model
if I do attributions with respect to the
true labels I get one vector of
attribution scores
if I do attributions with respect to the
predicted labels I get a totally
different set of attribution scores
and that confronts you with the
difficult conceptual question of which
ones you want to use to guide your
analysis there giving us different
pictures of this model and I think that
there is no a priori reason to favor one
over the other I think it really comes
down to what you're trying to accomplish
with the analysis that you're
constructing and so the best answer I
can give is to be explicit about your
assumptions and about the methods that
you used
this issue by the way will carry forward
through all of these gradient based
methods not just inputs by gradients
here's the fundamental sticking point
for gradients by inputs it fails that
sensitivity Axiom this is an example a
counter example to sensitivity that
comes directly from sundara Rajan at all
2017. we have a very simple model here M
it takes one dimensional inputs and what
it does is one minus the relu activation
applied to 1 minus the input very simple
model
when we use the model with input 0 we
get 0 as the output
when we use the model with input 2 we
get 1 as the output so we have a
difference in output predictions these
are one-dimensional inputs so we are now
required by sensitivity to give non-zero
attribution to this feature
but sadly we do not when you run input
by gradients on this input you get zero
and when you want run input by gradients
on input 2 you also get 0 and that is
just a direct failure to meet the
sensitivity requirement so that's a
worrisome thing about this Baseline
method it queues us up nicely to think
about how integrated gradients will do
better
the intuition behind integrated
gradients is that we are going to
explore counter factual versions of our
input and I think that is an important
insight as we try to get causal insights
into Model Behavior it becomes ever more
essential to think about counterfactuals
here's the way IG does this we have two
features in our space X1 and X2 and this
blue dot represents the example that we
would like to do attributions for
with integrated gradients the first
thing we do is set up a Baseline and a
standard Baseline for this would be the
zero vector
and then we are going to create
synthetic examples interpolated between
the Baseline and our actual example and
we are going to study the gradients with
respect to every single one of these
interpolated examples aggregate them
together and use all of that information
to do our attributions
here's a look at the IG calculation in
some detail as you might implement it
for an actual piece of software let's
break this down into some pieces step
one we have this Vector Alpha and this
is going to determine the number of
steps that we use to get different
synthetic inputs between Baseline and
the actual example
we're going to interpolate these inputs
between the Baseline and the actual
example that's what happens in purple
here
according to these Alpha steps and then
we compute the gradients for each
interpolated input and that part of the
calculation the individual ones looks
exactly like inputs by gradients of
course
next step we do an integral
approximation through the averaging
that's the summation that you see we're
going to so we're going to sum over all
of these examples that we've taken and
created the gradients for
and then finally we do some scaling to
remain in the space region of the
original example and that is the
complete IG calculation
let's return to sensitivity we have our
our model M with these one-dimensional
inputs one minus relu applied to 1 minus
X this is the example from sundara Rajan
at all I showed you before that inputs
by gradients fail sensitivity for this
example in this model
integrated gradients does better and the
reason it does better you can see this
here we are summing over all of those
gradient calculations and kind of
averaging through them and the result of
all of that summing and averaging is an
attribution of approximately one
depending on exactly which steps that
you decide to look at for the IG
calculation
so this example is no longer a sense of
a counter example to sensitivity and in
fact it's provable that IG satisfies the
sensitivity Axiom
let's think in Practical terms now we're
likely to be thinking about Bert style
models this is a kind of cartoon version
of Bert where I have some output labels
up here at the top I have a lot of
hidden States and I have a lot of things
happening all the way down to maybe
multiple and fixed embedding layers and
the fundamental thing about IG that
makes it so freeing is that we can do
attributions with respect to any neuron
in any state in this entire model and so
we have some of the flexibility of
probing but now we will get causal
guarantees that our attributions relate
to the causal efficacy of neurons on
input output Behavior
here's a complete worked example that
you might want to work with yourselves
modify study and so forth let me walk
through it at a high level for now the
first thing I do is load in a Twitter
based sentiment classifier based in
Roberta that I got from hugging face for
the sake of Captain you'd need to Define
your own probabilistic prediction
function and you need to define a
function that will create for you
representations for your base as well as
for your actual example those are the
things that will interpolate between
with IG
you need to do one more function to find
the forward part of your model here I
just needed to grab the logits and then
IG forward and whatever layer I pick are
the core arguments to layer integrated
gradients for captum
here's my example this is Illuminating
it has true class positive I'll take
attributions with respect to the
positive class the true class
here are my base and actual inputs
and here's the actual attribution step
inputs Base IDs the target is the true
class and this is some other keyword
argument the result of that is some
scores which I use and then I kind of
z-score normalize them across individual
representations in the Bert model that's
an additional assumption that I'm
bringing in that we'll do kind of
averaging of attributions across these
hidden representations
a little more calculating and then cap
them provides a nice function for
visualizing these things and so what you
get out are little Snippets of HTML that
summarize the attributions and
Associated metadata I've got the true
label the predicted label those align
um there's some scores and I'm not sure
actually what attribution label is
supposed to do but the nice thing is
that we have color coding here with
color proportional to the attribution
score you have to be a little bit
careful here green means evidence toward
the positive label which in sentiment
might be negative this is meant to be
the true label and negative is evidence
away from the true label and the white
there is neutral
so here's a fuller example and for this
one to avoid confusing myself I did
re-label the legend away from the true
label neutral with respect to the true
label and toward the true label so this
is kind of very intuitive where the true
label is positive we get strong
attributions for great where the true
label is negative we get strong
attributions for words like wrong and
less activation for things like great
this is kind of intuitive here that
we're getting more activation for said
than for great suggesting the model has
learned that the reporting verb there
kind of modulates the positive sentiment
that is in its scope
and then down at the bottom here we have
one of these kind of tricky situations
the true label is zero the predicted
label is one these are attributions with
respect to the true label so we're
seeing for example that incorrect is
biased toward negative my guess about
these attributions is that the model is
actually doing pretty well with this
example and may be missed for some
incidental reason
but overall I would say qualitatively
this slide is a kind of reassuring
picture that the model is doing
something systematic with its features
in making the sentiment predictions
so to summarize feature attribution can
give okay characterizations of the
representations you really just get a
scalar value about the degree of
importance and you have to make further
guesses about why examples are sorry
representations are important but it's
still useful guidance
we can get causal guarantees when we use
models like iiig
but I'm afraid that there's no clear
direct path to using methods like IG to
directly improve models it's kind of
like you've just got some ambient
information that might guide you in a
subsequent and separate modeling step
that would improve your model
so that's a summary feature attribution
of powerful pretty flexible heuristic
method that can offer useful insights
about how models are solving tasks